it so we can start the second panel of
today please
so I'd like to have within our next
panel urban pratik estate critique and
our first panelist sylvia pariah is a
PhD candidate at escuela técnica
superior de arquitectura universidad
politécnica de madrid and she's also a
visiting scholar and Department of
Architecture Columbia University and her
papers called resistance in progress the
cultural project of Lina Bo Bardi in the
Northeast of Brazil nineteen fifty eight
to nineteen sixty-four and the second
paper will be presented by cleric are
you who's an assistant professor in the
Department of urbanism at universiti a
pal us non Kerala non telephones and her
paper is called the complex relations
between social criticism and the state
in France 1970s and the final paper will
be presented by Francesco fiorelli a PhD
candidate at escuela técnica superior de
arquitectura Universidad de Navarra in
her paper is Milan 1944 251 the
definitive plan versus official city
planning Thank You ginger and thank you
all of you for being here this morning
the pairing of architecture and the
state generally refers to a historical
condition of dependence in which the
first term serves as an instrument of
the second with an explicit purpose of
representation of its image in
anticipation of such dependence Lina Bo
Bardi lates the political ambition of
her work towards the identification
between people and state in a free
democratic and participatory unit
although she identified herself with his
cousin said youth it is not until her
first date in the Northeast of Brazil
between nineteen fifty eight and
nineteen sixty four after nearly 20
years of professional experience that it
becomes a comprehensive and leading
product
multiple facets of her work even if
relying on the margin of autonomy that
she attained through a persistent
cultivation or respect towards her work
hobart is crowded will find in a mass
politics of the federal government
enforce as well as in the financial
support of the state of paya to
conducive contingencies for its
objectives on a local scale it will
aspire to promote social change through
the intensification of culture on a
larger it will attempt to stimulate
Brazil's uneven economic growth by
calling the attention to the balance
between economic functional
anthropological an aesthetic values
proper to its popular culture the
analyzes of the ideal ideological
position from which her plan arises as
well as a form and the function that is
specified aims to illustrate a rare case
of relationship between architecture and
the state in which the latter plays a
supportive role in itself a structural
redefinition the ultimate objective of
bo buddies project Lina Bo Bardi
decision not to join in a political
party and more specifically the
Communists which actually represented
her social ideal was likely not because
of a lack of affinity with the party's
ideology but because of her own
political conviction devoid of all
nationalist fervor in favour of national
identity anti-imperialist in the pursuit
of a pluralistic global culture an
anti-capitalist in the defense of a
democratic social rise of the working
masses her political profile is marked
by an attitude of resistance towards
immobility and oppression a proactive
attitude built-up through her living
experience of Mussolini's regime and the
Second World War both inspire her to
embrace a free progressive and
democratic concept of a state to which
she enthusiastically fell close well
vism barking in Brazil an unimaginable
country where everything was possible in
her words the same resistance and hope
that base her commitment to improve the
daily lives of detail and work in masses
by stressing the need for a general
of their reality motivated her political
aspirations to overcome Brazil's under
development by calling for a national
ethic responsibility still deeply rooted
in its indigenous and colonial past the
country's northeast culture according to
go body percentage signs of social
authenticity that could provide a state
for such national development in line
with the measures they can buy the
successive governments of Brazil's
liberal Republic to equalize the
economic differences between the
nation's northern and southern
hemispheres boo body and her husband
Pietro Maria body helped to disseminate
those ethnographic values in the
cosmopolitan sell the regular inclusion
of exhibitions of north-eastern popular
production in the museum of art of Sao
Paulo where Pietro was director and Lina
architect Imperator as well as of
related articles in the magazine Abby
that that they founded in the same city
help to familiarize both regions and to
satisfy the country's need of a stronger
definition for cultural identity capable
of shrinking its inferiority complex
regarding the Western world the body
satellite report activity in the early
50s took on a local and greater than
mention for Bo Bardi in 1959 when she
accepted the invitation of the governor
of by ado de cima Goliath to found a
directive Museum of Modern Art in
Salvador aimed at representing the
regional state incorporation to the
institutional modernization impulse that
the nation was experiencing bo-buddies
participation in setting the exhibition
via within the fifth biennial of arts of
some foul on the other hand sealed her
commitment to the polarization of
Brazil's North East pre arts and crafts
conceived as a manifesto against the
soulless art that she found was the
starting to spread through the global
market the show focused on illustrating
the region's anthropological aspect of
its daily life object bringing the
superstitious and the anonymous into the
commercial and led
atmosphere of the biennial was according
to her a declaration of resistance to
the perversions of capital a provocation
the show promoters got to share with a
den President of the Republic ugilino KU
b.tech by anticipated boob artists
crusade to overcome the north eastern
cultural and social backwardness by
betting on the transformative power of
culture an objective that found an echo
in the aspiration of students and
faculty members of the University of
Baia eager to make Salvador Brazil's
arts epicenter along with them and
counting on the unconditional support of
the governor of the state she conducted
a socio-cultural renovation project
through an intensive program of
activities related to earth who-who's
exceptionality in the city earn it the
name of avant-garde although there are
efforts to turn the culture into the
touchstone of a new social paradigm were
aligned with the measures taken by
president john kohler to favor the
rights of the lower classes their
political discourse did not have
electoral overtones however it fiercely
demanded a state freed from the
semi-feudal condition that dominated the
country's less industrialized areas
hinting at a parallel between Brazil's
economic situation during the liberal
Republic and that of Russia during the
series period and alluding to the early
20th century Russian revolutionary
thesis obadi expressed his claim in
terms of a bourgeois democratic
revolution according to these theses
such revolution was the only possible
means for the development of socialism
in a capitalist country here to an
oligarchic social political structure
and undergoing a radical process of
industrialization as was the case of
Brazil at a time given these conditions
the Russian theorist stated only the
broadening of the bourgeois capitalist
base could allow the working masses
access to education to labor unions and
eventually to power despite the historic
confirmation of these theories amber
bodies assertive
defense of them could such bull a
democratic revolution have been possible
by that time in Brazil if it was common
knowledge that the surname populists
that the left-wing bulrushes champion
was an interested resource to hold back
the power of right-wing entrepreneurs it
is likely that through the criticism of
bourgeois materialism which appears
repeatedly in her texts and
illustrations bo bardi would seek to
promote a certain popular spirit in the
advantage class and that with her
emphasis on the popular production
ethical values she would want to
persuade its behavior but where these
measures are strong enough to commit the
bourgeoisie with her aim of a state have
not had been for the approach between
people and culture that he'll project
attained the revolution she presented
first step this one could have been
labeled as idealistic more so giving the
architects lack of the specification of
a method methodology for conducting such
bourgeois Democratic upheaval the
military group of 1964 that follow her
project implementation prevents and now
whether despite it it's loose ends the
straight she dreamt of could have been a
real possibility inspired by the
simplicity and the functionality of the
military and primitive architecture of
the Northeast the multiple facets of Lin
upper bodies by inactivity are brought
together under the ambivalent sign of a
solid and vulnerable nature hers is a
non-formal is though symbolic language
non indolent but deeply independent non
romantic syncretic distance from the
acrobatics that she identified in many
of the state institute for institutional
promotions her work manifests the social
political aspiration of her project
through different aspects on the one
hand it reflects for barda's goal to
bring high culture to the buy-ins daily
life in this regard the choice of the
crystalline volume of the theater castro
elvis hall to help the museum of modern
art of bahia the mum is especially
significant transparent and accessible
from the street level the man serves
and the pill and showcase hinting at its
activity and content to the passers-by
parallel to its public openness the use
of curtains floor-to-ceiling in its
interior enhance the special continuity
between exhibitions allowing its Hall to
profit from the visitors of the
contiguous on the other hand the
architects campaign to place cultural
heritage among the pillars of Brazil's
pride to fight a feeling of inferiority
that prevailed among its people
illustrate her commitment towards what
she understood by national following
Antonio Bram see who she regularly
quoted who body associated national with
the real values of a country that is
those things of a country's history and
cultural essence that were part of its
collective unconscious robot is critical
restoration of the solid anyang the 16th
century architectural site to set up the
museum of popular art of salvador the
map who exemplifies her contribution to
stress those national values the
critical procedure that she carried out
in the salar combined the conservation
of the side poetic historical aspects
such as the sayings of its colonial and
enslave past with its special adaptation
to those days needs and in line with her
commitment to the public enjoyment of
the site's heritage value she limited
the x novo operations to the
introduction of a staircase whose
assembly inspired in the joint system of
bullock carts epitomize the spirit of
the intervention in a naturalized
primitivism my body's defense of the
popular production phase to the imported
control schemes that brazil of brazil's
progressive western colonization did not
imply a melancholic attitude but a wheel
to maintain the anthropological value of
the popular production in its adaptation
to industry the need of stressing the
popular art collective illusion versus
the shallowness of the teach a product
paternally protected by the bourgeoisie
as she used to say inspire the
exhibition or desde with which the map
was inaugurated
in 1963 presented again as a manifesto
against the personalization of
civilizations prompted by poetic and
economic dictatorships nervous to
symbolize according to the architect a
desperate cultural effort this
exhibition is untidy she wrote it does
not represent the puebla spaniel up
definitely Sima Franco nor the
Portuguese bandidas of the tercel Assad
neither destroyed by a sea of the
partido nationally fastest it is just a
review of Brazilian rural popular
aristocracy alienated by the
monocultures this is a poetic exhibition
of course it is also devoted to the
consumer society forced to get rid of
objects that should lasted a lifetime
end quote finally Bovard is valiant work
manifests her demand of the state
capable of promoting the country's
development according to existing
technical economic and human resources
through a language that she called poor
for she stated not in the sense of
poverty neither wanted to mean a
merciful attitude but regarding the
simplicity of the means of production
her designs for the stage architecture
of the threepenny opera and Caligula
which took place in the theater castor
oil Elvis in 1960 and 1961 respectively
exemplify the breadth of the social
outreach that her claim made possible
regarding the representation of Caligula
she stated the poverty of all the high
walls austerity the very concrete the
roof exposed the structure instead of
sucking the public transported Apes
efecto to the moderns world's reality
and truth this is not to say that our
theater has to be voluntarily and
definitely poor but experience has
lovely shown us that the crisis of
theater does not exist when it comes out
of a privileged class to target all even
if financially supported by the original
estate the implementation of the mam and
the map who faced serious economic
limitations this fact instill in bhiwadi
our discipline based on simplification
would reach acute levels in her later
brutalist work faithful to her will to
popularize culture to foster the
country's identity and to promote a
humanized industrial design and a
civilized progress pobody's million
production trigger an autonomous
political language that aim at is
strengthening the link between people
and culture in order to end with the
country's social injustice 'as the
project of Lina Bo Bardi in salvador is
not only independent because of the
ideological position from which it
arises not because of its formal
manifestation its role essentially
didactic lies at the merging of the
traditional methods and goals of
education and ultimately is political
supported by a free egalitarian and
pragmatic system of education capable of
encouraging solidarity moral autonomy
and self-discipline in civil society her
project pursued a model of the state
rooted in a school bo buddies idea for
school was addressed to quote a state
able to provide away everyone without
distinction a creative method through
science and life a method who the
spreading would be monopoly of the
school and out of the chances of
practical life and quote considering it
the country's culture school was meant
to be the place where the democratic
revolution she defended could be birthed
this idea will find an echoing their
heads on that of the movement of popular
culture a set of educational strategies
especially aimed at the northeastern
working masses that combine basic
learning and politics sought to a victim
for social struggle besides fully
sharing these strategies for various
activities didactic base corresponded
not only to her academic vocation that
she practiced widely in Sao Paulo and in
Salvador but also to the need of
providing herself a defensive position
against her project detractors the
didactic and usually in intimidating
tone that she used for example in her
articles for cronicas a cultural
supplement of the diario de noticias de
salvador reflected her
geological competitiveness in trying to
ethically persuade the reader among the
social is among the many social issues
she tackled the state finance
architectural social or disarm upper
days the self-centered interests of the
vajra see the countries in human land
speculation the automated education
imported impart imparted by the Academy
among others supported her project basis
of biding everything that led to the
nation's social and cultural immobility
along with her teaching and editorial
activities the music graphical
strategies developed by bombarding
bhaiya were meant to make exhibitions as
educational as possible so that an
unfamiliar public koukin could
comprehensively access the world of art
considering that a modern museum apart
from conserving its collections had to
provide a means to transmit the
historical continuity of arts ba body
combined shows of different nature
artists and times by doing so she aimed
at ending with the early differentiation
between major and minor arts at
introducing to the people art freed from
its commercial value as well as at
presenting it as a trans historical
phenomenon the educational purpose of
the man that in addition to the museum
facilities contagion a school of
artistic initiation for children would
articulate the miscellaneous functions
of the map who from it's very inception
labeled as northeastern technical
studies and popular our documentation
center the map who was conceived
primarily as a school where popular and
industrial design could be mutually
supportive including workshops
classrooms and an auditorium the map was
objective was to assure the local
production know how survival through its
academic spreading and to produce a type
of good industrial design affordable to
everyone two objectives difficult to
make work synergistically as per body
wished although the social effects of
her educational campaigning by are
difficult to quantify the architects
achievement is utterly related with
instilling in the lower classes
a sense of responsibility towards the
matter of the state such as education no
less important was her a contribution to
disseminate more than art in the North
East nor her support of popular values
which for many were insignificant or
Hitler tooth and known in the very midst
of lina bo buddies project sedimentation
shortly after the military group of 1964
that ended the country's liberal
republic the military took over the man
by force and set up without Lina Bo
Bardi consent and exhibition about
subversion with intention of warning
society about the dangers of communism
this event would force the architecture
resigned from the museum's direction and
to live bhaiya it would also mark the
beginning of a professional downturn for
her that lasted almost 20 years until
the dictatorship favored the transition
towards democracy Bob artists departure
from Salvador left her plan in suspense
but her contributions kept her memory
alive among these there can be counted
courses lectures to museums over a
hundred exhibitions a film club on
artistic initiation children school to a
theatre play set designs and a popular
college on the rise by the end of the
decade of 1960s the repression against
communists got critical Bo Bardi herself
was recorded as a member of the pop
Larry poplar revolutionary avant-garde a
terrorist group accused of threatening
social order and had to spend some
months away from Brazil along with the
meteoric industrialization process that
the country experienced after she left
the Northeast the Astoria with of its
largest cities and the opening of its a
stocked change to the global market and
at her dream of a revolution capable of
placing people ahead of the process of
national modernization Brazil could have
upheld a human unlimited ordem a
progressive but in my body's words it
shows the finesse she did not although
by the end of the dictatorship her
expectations of building a new reality
had been reduced the
context-aware works these sale today
invite us to imagine that those
expectations were built upon the same
fascination as when in the country
according to her everything was possible
thank you
so thank you for bein here on first of
all I would like to apologize for my
English which is not very good so i hope
i will be understood and i hope i really
be able to answer to your question so
this paper will focus on the dynamics
between architecture planning and states
concerning the french housing production
in the 17th ok so this year's lay at a
juncture in france because they were
marked by a social crisis so you have
all thought about may 68 and then by an
economic crisis and they witnessed a
recomposition of the centralized housing
production models that had predominated
up to them in fact they marked the end
of the policy of what we call in france
because of some that is to say the large
housing complex's which were organized
by the state so i would like to focus
here on the way in which the housing
production model changed during this
year's first i will show how the
mainstream of the change came from
social house social criticism of the
state coming from outside the states
through student protests on social
movements which were fighting against
the sunrise production model and the new
generation of city planners and
architects played a key role in this
protest process and then i will show how
the social movement was partly related
and supported inside the state by the
same professionals in a global context
marked by to ground tendencies
progressive installation of your van
sociology and growing trends toward
decent realization as you will see the
relations between social criticism and
states are complex and perhaps one of
the best expression to describe this
dialectical process is one of Miss
Michelle I'm you everyone against the
state with which reflects both the
complex movement of opposition and
support for state involvement so against
and against as very close so in fact you
see that it's not so clear to this tank
which to distinguish what is inside and
what is outside the state's operation
and also it's not so clear to say what
constitutes estate so before i come to
the seventies i will briefly come back
to the 50s and 60s to expose use the
extent of the change the first thing to
say that after the Second World War
architectural Europe and production was
highly centralized so in the outing
field this period was characterized by
standardized production organized from
Paris architects were chosen by central
governments and they were frequently
institutional architects or winners of
national prices like Rome prizes it
happened in the context of the French
welfare state dating back to 45 in which
estate was a key actor in the economic
in social sphere and it was a chief
organizer of the general interest and of
the couch and the guarantor of social
justice and in this system housing has
always been an historical key component
in in the social reform so as I said
architects were involved in the new
centralized production model they work
directly with both public authorities
and construction lobbies but actually
the whole has to be minimized for at
least two reasons first they appeared
aside from any real decision-making
power which was which remains or
prerogative of administrator technicians
builders & state engineers and secondly
they were they were not prepared for
this new social programs which were so
different from the prestigious public
Commission they were used to such as
courthouses ministry city halls of
public edifices so they showed an
obvious lack of affinity with the usage
value of ordinary housing here you have
a example of the gospel sermon in
northern Paris so in this period there
were a few criticism of this production
model coming also from bureaucrats and
from inhabitants but this remain Willy
marginal by the end of the sea
however there was a big change in public
opinion and the image of lagavulin this
way of producing the city was no gravity
city side and what is important to
underline in regard to our conference is
that this criticism came mostly from
Yerevan social movements they were
organized against the state technical
interventionist policy and this protest
came from the new middle classes that
defended alternative values based on
current reality and exchange and they
came also from the young urban
professionals architects and town
planners who wish to develop new
architectural and urban practices they
were also trying to define a place for
themselves in a production process that
was largely dominated by their elders
the students the teachers who have been
influenced by the counterculture from
the architecture define department of
fine art school play the big part in
this process they were heavily involved
in the events of of May 68 which was
also an urban protest and among these we
can't I find major architects of the
period but architects who had taken
unorthodox routes but also young
architect and the object of their
protest was two-fold so the first one
concerns directly this top-down
centralized production process process
that is to say the way the state
organized the European production these
movements asked to share power local
levels and even for self-management
French ideas when he influenced by
international experiences such as as a
renovation of Bologna in the late
sixties or the German experiences so
here you have posters that were yeah
that were on the world yeah in in Paris
so the second point of the protest
concern modern architecture and urban
planning principle which were attached
to this way of producing the city we can
read it for example in
helo facebook ledroit reveal published
in 68 oh he'll FF became also one of the
theoretician of this radical student
demands he denounced the functional
alienating an individual suntrek city
planning policies he called for the
reinvention of your band centrality to
bring back the recreational function of
a city in other words a city that
provides a medium for wishes images in
social appropriation he also called for
social sciences to be introduced into
the yerevan production process and we
could observe at this time a growing
interest for your band sociology and
also a call for participation by local
inhabitants so in this intellectual
context number of young architects on
sociology professionals turn to the
morphological past of the historical
city the remark that old city and town
centres where an hour medium for usages
so they try to analyze how their social
meaning was an East composed their aim
was to understand the link the
historical link between their forms and
social practices because they wanted to
perpetrate it in the new part of the
city so here you have example of
research with which were engaged in the
70s on on what recording friends the
type of morphology of for example the
Osmond and part of Paris and yeah these
movements brought change in the programs
of the school of architecture where
social science is phased in the rotor
also changes the private command but
these movements had other effects also
in the state and local government bodies
like ministries and municipalities
indeed they also change the route for
public comment because some of the same
radical young architects and planners
had a voice within the French ministries
for Public Works and Cultural Affairs
where the camera dots to do a contextual
position their convictions crust those
of a few
krotz we were marked by social
convictions and convinced of the need to
adapt public policy especially in order
to decentralize some some competencies
for them however it was it was not
however always easy to hold such
positions in front of a frequently
hostile administration of some part
government but in this period we could
observe a strange union between the
anti-establishment tendency and a
certain number of top officials a number
of bodies observe you move out of these
conversions of these two universes at
both central and municipal levels among
these experiences I can mention the
foundation of the pro constrictions of
building program in the ministry for
Public Works in 71 this body was
dedicated to promoting research and
innovation in the building sector it
provided a number of experimental
construction and recommendations
concerning participation it concerned
for example a new architecture program
for young architects and it concern also
the promotion of cohaagen so it's
important to monitor north of the
experience of the new towns built around
Paris during the 70's because they gave
the opportunity to this new aliens
between researchers senior officials
young engineers and architects and city
planners professionals and
decision-makers saw them as a great
opportunity to break with the way of
producing legal form and to come back to
a certain vision of the European city so
it opens the door for European
alternative an experimental approach in
terms of participation and architecture
planning and you can see here on the
photo architecture was still influenced
by functionalist conceptions but it try
to reintroduce sound while structures
that would create such ability and
reconnect buildings with the street
another great example of this type of
experimentation
is the Alma rail station in who bane's a
lot of friends in this case young
architects and planners set up a popular
planning workshop to receive local
wishes into a counter project a counter
project against the one of the states
which aims to totally destroy the place
and two to make new buildings but in a
modern way so and here you can see the
people we are discussing about the
project and on this poster you can see
how the inhabitants reject the
traditional way of producing social
housing this is a man of on the left
side so and in this case the church
shows an architecture wished to be
respectful of the traditional Europe and
forms so here you have a mixed actually
between traditional urban form and model
influence so in the 70s we could observe
several exchanges between social
criticism and States protest was
directed against the states mostly by
young architects Urbanists and planning
professionals but these professionals
asked also for state support for their
initiatives again the centralized
production and it actually found a
certain eco within the state power at
the central and local levels so to
conclude I would like to point out shree
remark so first remark this process
shows how the state was so present on
central in France in this year's so
that's a social movement in France bill
death social and political identity
protesting against the state but and
this will be my second remark these
movements lead us to reconsider the
binary analysis of political dynamics
which is party inhibited from this
period and so political dynamics which
put the state and its institution on the
one hand and social movements and social
criticism on the other as if the two
were strictly opposed
at the contrary when we look more
precisely at these movements we can see
how it is difficult to say what is in
what is out the state's operation and to
draw a clear front red frontier between
between the two so this remark invites
us at least to minimize the myth of the
all-powerful a Germanic state that was
so present in the masses interpretation
in France so in the way it appears much
more at as a non unitary non homogenous
and marked with the center certain
number of conflict so answered remark I
have to notice that this exchange
between social criticism and state had
little long-term effects regarding the
aesthetic part of the criticism we could
see emerge a new architectural and
planning current that is quite well
represented in France it is based on
both attention to the history of Europe
and forms and public spaces in
architectural and urbanity design so
French famous French architect until
until today come from these movements
and also the growing interest for public
spaces however as regard participation
the dynamic established in this year's
never really got beyond the social
experiments phase so innovations remains
limited so it would confirm the analysis
of liberal tolsky concerning the new
spirit of capitalism whereas the
artistic criticism was incorporated into
the fabrication of neoliberal lifestyles
site email during this period the
political part of the criticism tend to
be marginalized so we could ask a
question was it away for the state to
maintain its position thank
I would like to Cornell University for
giving me the opportunity to be here
today Milan 1946 an architect claimed
the city after the world is like a big
machine that needs to be started up
again a big company that needs to be
reorganized work not only stopped any
kind of development but he also
destroyed about a third of it it's not a
mistake to say that is urgent to rebuild
half of Milan his architect was just a
definitive in November 1959 the Italian
magazine Casa Bella published a
monograph dedicated to the professional
activity of huddle flows a brief
biographical note about the architect
that accompanies the volume states in
1907 06 loss created a school of her
kids really involved involving among
holders and Rick Olga and definitive
juice up a definite team who belong to
to the group of official student of the
school was among those who part in Los
circuit affirmed with units allow a
deeper understanding of the cultural
background of molina's architect who was
extreme bound to a specific a European
context that is strongly affected his
education and its work is creative and
planning work although developed in a
state of parcel culture isolation from
9022 9051 may reasonably be considered
another view of studies and project
devoted to the city the professional
definitely consider theory and critique
is an essential tool for research
determined to be a project of reforms
the city it could potentially have
activated its reform project during this
participation in politics and local
government as a representative of the
national liberation committee in the
provincial reputation of Milan member of
the Council of interference supporter
congresses conferences and
reserved to the family matically in 20
via run phenomenon dark it is what this
an inspired by Central European RT 22
definitive fits I'm romantically into
the context of urban and architectural
development of the city of Milan after
the damages caused by the Second World
War beside this the theoretical
experience of an important unfinished
editorial project milano resort and the
publication of the periodical la teta
periodically arcata to a political
define his work is a contribution for
the completion of the new reform to
which the city is parked the
reconstruction of Milan seen as the
fulcrum of industrial overview of not
north anita acts as a catalyst for a new
style and type of urban planning to be
taken into consideration exceeded to
real scale of an urban project that
leads to a debate on our territory scale
world economic and demographic social
and political factors proved to be
aspect of a reality that is constantly
child by the passing of history to
opposing the earth parallel work exists
in definitive the world of the antivenin
professional as well as delta T
collaborator in the public sector
however his role was rather than an
insulated scientists who did not side
with any other social forces in star war
but was small and expert poverty parties
it's a resolute as to beam as a thorough
study that moves beyond the program felt
and makes programmatic proposal for a
city that has been destroyed but it is
going to recover in the development of
Israeli about and for Milan he has
driven by increasing optimism and
practice principles that lead him to
anticipate hypothesis on the feasibility
and assassins of future interventions in
1943 the series of articles la cocina de
la cita felicita Lumira written Bosma
published for the newspaper Isola was
the first step of an organic reflection
on Milan this reflection aimed at
deeper understanding of the city
structure and its mechanism of
development therefore the study of the
city of the past it in its urban
relation under physical form be climbing
the basis for developing no theory for
reconstruction but reader pragmatic
proposal for action this proposal were
not limited to empty criticism of the
contemporary situation but were intended
to give rise to the formulation of
methodical intention programs and plans
in his work based on a systematic study
of analysis of interpretation city lives
he lined his salient apparatus of his
research aimed at providing the city
with a new Olympic level plan tailored
to the changing needs of the city that
was in after mark of the world
destruction according to the phonetic an
urban plan is on the one hand invention
and on the other deduction like every
other task in our PT to an urban plan is
a work of art composed on various
concrete mixes I'm compelling reason
this type of plan a synthetic size a
plethora of factor from geographic to
historical from demographic to cinematic
and from economic to the financial
definitely study can be reconsidered as
a result of the past for the future of
the city perhaps this metallurgical idea
would explain his interest in Napoleon's
plans of 1807 as an example of
intervention to restructure the seeking
in contrast according to definity the
subsequent plans has no head to the
capacity to develop that joint proposal
but instead Admiral restored a sitting
fragment an irregular irregular
agglomeration thank you class the best
roles and hierarchy of the urban spaces
the first municipal council of the
post-world based on a lot of 1940 which
had imposed the suspension of all
activities of civil construction and
implemented a policy of prevention to
reconstruction based
guidelines from the urban plan of 1934
however a path of Allah has revealed the
ban of 1940 while at the same time
Albert a nice passes urban plan of 1934
was in force in this way Milan continue
to use an urban system guidelines that
has been defined for fifty hi two years
by the other lot of three different
plants this plans according to
definitive had had been more inefficient
unfaithful than the previous one two
years after the war definitely noted the
rising of the new building structure
native good of non warning that were
built around all of our guidelines or
alamitos defined by a plan which he said
had already proved fundamental mistake
knee in technical and financial
investment the local and provincial
administrative bodies supported a
climber of this plan by exercising the
state governments action status powers
and functions in the center for worse
the delegation system definitely too
small away from municipal and provincial
administrative policy distancing himself
from state policy and starting a
personal battle to give the city and
rubens instrument that was an efficient
response to the current or one develop
definitive also stated it's necessary to
start to continues as and well explained
elaboration of a new and different plan
toward the public opinion its individual
proposal based on the definition on the
framework of the city's plan consists on
the reform of the major security system
rock railways and public transport and
the rosa from the origination of current
economic trends and relationship with
the land and building on a large scale
of the portland the MFD proposal was to
release the city from the medieval
structure and from the mono centrism
imposed by false here is copied
for any example in the sense bring the
city from the historic seals and
eliminated insufficient idea on beltway
mint ensuring and a new vitality to a
spherical city center while
simultaneously creating a roadway along
which to the central area full of
interest and shopping attrition could
continue the new plan whatever needed to
be implementing starting from the
outside of the city and moving inward
general account and being consistent
with the historical heritage the
dominant geographical features the land
policy the continuity of urban fabric
the urban transport system the new
productive requirement and social and
economic balance in a letter of 1948 his
plane is the strategy of development of
the city ground for the receiver city
often used apparently knowledge with a
view of identification of target for
land sentiment and economic
entrepreneurship in the first part of of
this letter he noted that this city must
be developed by transplant not by
reconstruction of the paralysis and a
sufficient body under for it move
towards the northwest d key element of
his proposal is the creation of a
preferential northwest axis which would
provide the expansion of the city center
britain ties with the medieval structure
from this point of view the more
eccentric structure of Milan is
reconsider in accordance with a linear
development plan learn about the
consistence of the ball center restored
Milan with the new axis the possible
millen the urban and regional plan of
Northwest developed as a partial plan
represented concept of the urban master
plan of definitely that in concert to
the choices of the municipal master plan
recognized in the northwest is the
preferences
for the inspection of the city
activities residence fur around the new
renewed axis of connection and
penetration of the region definitely
proposed a v-shaped development of city
on a territorial scale in contrast to
the expansion in water which were
observed by millions city council in its
attempt to reconstruct the gaps left by
the destruction of the world after
identifying the suitable and preferred
area for expansion the plan consisted in
the overlap and interaction of
interventional different scale starting
with an appropriate historic and
topological reserved the city is a
superior entity into which the sequence
of intervention described it functional
and concept with wire is inserted in
technical terms according to definitely
the protest on small-scale shoulder to
the general urban plan itself
materialized in numerous concrete
examples developed at different little
of definition in this sense his plan is
not just or one but architettura as well
thus allowing through a valuable focus
to achieve a constant feedback between
the different scale of intervention
which are mutually defining and together
didn't mind plans congruence moreover
according to definite team the entire
study study is based on the twofold
proposition no transfer policies can
disassociate yourself from a land policy
Nolan policies can disassociate itself
from a transport policy according to
this point of view system of carbonyl
axis for regional and urban traffic and
the humans for freight and transit would
have allowed the city to acquire a new
territory appearance and new urban
quality hoping for the revival of the
seating seen as derived from the ashes
of the world the proposal review largely
on a concept of suitability in terms of
economy and quality personal strategy of
the compression of the urban fabric and
discovering their ideas supported by the
local authority
of exclusive and massive reconstruction
of the gap left by the world according
to the unity rebuilding only the urban
gaps would have dragged into the future
the program's recognized by the previous
program policy and what have resulted in
unbalanced it land value to the
treatment and general interest of proper
urban planning before all this it was
necessary to have a proper city
management system internet sub balancer
compromise between the political enemies
active management of the states and
economic entrepreneurial investment what
definity proposed to the provincial
municipal authority was to judge his
plan regarding it as a project of
courage or renunciation as well health
and in many cases a cancellation of
tools and reasonable elements from the
mistaken plans of the past however the
lack of concern within programmatic
guidelines and general objective of the
plan in 1946 let the architect to break
free from the so-called Parliament enum
the group of 56 technician in charge of
the new urban plan of Milan mr. is
represented for Jews Appel affinity the
possibility to conclude the drafting of
the tax milano resort which would have
finally contributed by shelli line on
the real problems of the city this
companion would have brought about the
probability of Critias and consciously
little choice made by the local council
endure for presented a citizen with a
concrete vision of possible city of
Milan in a series of vertical in every
15 he made public his disagreement with
the definition of millions Marshall
planet whose main feature was a
development of a new
system of primary axis which crossing in
the form of X led to establishment of a
new management center seen as the new
fulcrum of the urban microcosm
definitely speaks about microcosm with a
negative connotation not only in
reference to the modest extensive dr a
conserved multiple in relation to the
haight possibility perhaps amount of
saturation of the area of confluence
between the crypt axis provided by the
municipality the proposal of the state
is the formalizes server ejection of the
definition proposal for an opening
French ship sitting based on his 12 Sons
the state's proposal also reject the
develop of milan from our self our
knowledge nucleus to an open body a city
developed along the strong and
preference and lands comparing the
municipal plan presenting in 1950 and
the planned affinity presented some here
before it does not seem possible to
identify any common points but we can
notice a fundamental antithesis this
contradiction given the contribution for
of the administration can be summarized
as the lack of reciprocity between a
land policy and transport which
structure the entire definition urban
plan both a detailed rita real scale and
the specific intervention more generally
the municipal plan seemed to reflect and
massive attitude coming to support a
policy of private interest which
according to definitely could be
recognizing the reconstruction and
hinted and the valley decade of city
Civic spirit its innovative attitude as
led to a prolific definition of each
proposal submitted to the attention of
the provincial reputation it's possible
that a certain intensity termination of
his work could have been too strong for
the dominant public and private interest
especially in light of the possible
contingency and the resulting economic
insecurity associated with it in
addition one can think that the proposal
of definite
was inserted into a context of
diffidence and misunderstanding which
can be regarded as a one of main reasons
for the plans known acceptances by the
public Demi trust of the political class
and the proverb disinterest from the
professional progress environment
similar represent to Achilles high hill
or definite on proposal a proposal that
was on the one hand perhaps to extract
in terms of definition of intervention
with possibly did not seem to respond to
the most immediate verba necessity in
the close filter on the other hand it
was perhaps too concrete referring to
the highest level of definition of the
crucial point apparently without living
room for the brothers theoretical
reflection nevertheless then twist into
plan definitely it's wandering bound to
his anticipatory thinking as measured by
guido Cannella we found it to the
contradiction which now more than ever
are incumbent on the city between the
public inertia and the private
transgression approximately 40 here
after the definitive plan the same canal
and noted that during more than a
century the Milanese urban plan at
contradicted a polycentric structure by
which the city was linked to the
territory its gravitation it is in its
sense that the juicer definitive work
must be heard as a valid or thousand
official clearly official proposal
definitely proved that he had understood
the physiology of Milan with a great
inclination to realize however be
speculative municipality perhaps
business and hydrological interest of
marginalized his experience from the
decision for story in town and country
in spite of all this is necessary to
note that even food the definitive
proposal was a result of his personal
initiative
it was also based on extensive
interviews even early involvement with
Sunbrella design content organizational
capacity and significant mobilization of
resources definitely looked forward to a
coordination carry out to buy an
institutional figure in a position to
cross that we to the arcata consider to
the limits of a myopic view of the
state's action reflected in the field of
civic administration because of this
hope his proposal is given greatest
social content as as initiative of the
two enterpreneur intervention grilling
not in terms of private interest and
aiming to speculation that should have
joined the state planning however in a
conference of interns within the same
political hierarchies Milano researcher
is a proposal that has remained on paper
this project and in manuscript as large
scale of theoretical reflection until
nineteen sixty-nine the year of its
person and the bites and posthumous
publication thank you very much
so I want to thank you very much for
three papers which demonstrate very well
I think in different ways the complexity
of the relationships between
architecture in the state in efforts at
urban development and reform in the
post-war decades and I was thinking
while you were all presenting about how
to identify and really compare the
different ways in which critique is
operating within your papers and I was
struck by a paradox i think it was most
explicitly made you know brought out by
claire's paper but i think it was also
implicit in the other three namely that
there was actually a very intricately
involved relationship between political
collaboration and political critique and
so I'd like to sort of pose that
question generally maybe to all three of
you but also I have specific points to
raise i think in relation to the three
papers the question about the general
one being what really is this
relationship between collaboration and
critique and critique and so for for
Claire I mean you'd initially posed a
question of what it means for criticism
to come within the state come from
within the state for the state to be
sort of critiquing itself and and I
thought this was interesting because in
some ways you know a democratic regime
is one could see arguably specifically
that it's it's something which has
co-opted the mechanisms of criticism
from the outside into itself and I think
this might be it's sort of funny I when
I was reading your paper initially I was
thinking too that there's some
difference between thompson this is an
american where there's been a continuity
of a regime over you know 200-some years
versus you know France were this the
succession of regimes but and there was
this this detail you also brought up in
your longer version of your paper about
the ducati a where you have this
mechanism of eggettes neighborhood watch
is the what we have here
in English the where the state is
relinquishing its own responsibilities
or you know of policing basically and
yet the citizens are taking them up upon
themselves he's saying mechanisms of
policing so it's it's actually and I
think you said this was brought about by
as a initially was brought about because
there was 40 cab state power citizens
wanting to assume more control with the
good troll they're assuming is actually
the sort of control the state would be
assuming anyway it seems well though
there might have been a difference and
this question you raised then and that
your conclusion that your quote from
balt on ski about about art criticism
and how that operates within the
neoliberal state and in contrast of
political criticism I'd be tested
whether you see that as sort of working
as in a collaborative way with power
then I mean you should you sort of raise
this question yourself I think and so
then with a Sylvia's paper it's very
interesting because it first you
mentioned how vardi made the decision
not to join the Communist Party for for
various reasons and one can't help but
wonder because she's although she's
working you know from the left it also
seems that she's working within state
apparatus is like the institutions of
museum institutions of public education
and so she's very much working within
the system but with a kind of different
agenda perhaps and yet then it comes out
at the end that she actually resigns
from these positions because of a
political difference so so I guess I'd
just like to see how to what extent he
saw that she could actually work within
the state like what were the limit of
that lower the limits of collaboration
in that situation finally with
Francesca's paper um I think in some
ways you hadn't necessarily raised the
so explicitly this idea of the critique
of the state and in some ways maybe were
imposing this on you because of the
panel's topic but
so but I think it's interesting because
it seems like the definitive plan would
be the perfect plan for a neoliberal
state and in that and yet the state was
the one who rejected it and and I be
interested to hear a little bit more
than about like these practices of
mapping and the ideas of sort of you
could see this in some ways at the
actual perfect architectural realization
of a more abstract concept of
collaboration you know versus critique
and so far as the very specific ways and
use the word transplant i think but is
it actually very specific ways in which
definity is saying what should remain
and what should you know what should be
changed and there's so much it's very
it's he's going down to the small
details of that in a way that sort of
can incorporate what's there and make
certain concessions to it so and I guess
I'd like to ask you then because it
doesn't seem like there's a natural
ideological boutique at all and Ethan
Eddie's work or like I could be wrong I
like to ask whether you see him as
critiquing the state at all or he's
simply critiquing the state's failure to
bring about its own agenda through urban
reform so well I was leaving it a little
open to you but you wanted to talk about
the notions of collaboration and
critique but is that to open my would
like I'm not sure I could so yeah
perhaps one thing i can see that i can
say that it seemed actually really
really powered
as you say because these social
movements actually expressed some
protest and like they were fighting
against that clear with Lazio I just
explained against instead but when we
when we look at more precisely it seems
like more it appears like more
collaboration and I think that this way
of explaining explaining this process of
fighting states at social criticism
against eight so this by my revision is
probably it can be on appetizers is
probably a vision that was inherited
from this period itself so actually it
as if it was a main story to express
this process that helps probably to
construct the social criticism I can
explain what I mean I'm really sorry
with my English because it's hard to
explain these things in English for me
yeah what can I say also
this is actually we in France we are in
a period where will we try to to analyze
again this period so there are several
research on this female so for example
once the most famous one is by a liberal
funky with working on the way in which
the values of 68 we're totally
transformed and like we return I don't
know yeah transformed and integrated in
the lab around a lifestyle and actually
this remarks can be applied to this
subject about architecture instead so
it's ready for example I'm sure you you
are you always you have always heard
about John Bell for example which is
with one of the greatest architects
today in France and actually it was part
of the social movement student movement
in 68 so II at this time fight it
against the state but actually today is
one of the most institutional after date
is perhaps the best way to express this
way of the situation oh that's
interesting too because I think there is
in your paper and I think also in
Francesca's there's a notion of what's
being critiqued is actually the
architect role you know easily the state
by you know Technic mean I guess
definity was an architect by training
but by technocrats and people have taken
medicine in this case and the five
associate fullness social sciences and
planning so so maybe wanna case is very
interesting death
no communion Victor about the argument
of definitely and okay okay i talk about
little question for definitely it was a
priority to twitter the urban question
the Obama them with address systemic
intention and I think that is for this
reason I I speak about this mission plan
to abstract and 22 concrete and in the
sense i think that the state is not
prepared at that moment for except the
precise definition of the of the plan no
and for the forum and the first step
definitely collaborate with the state in
the deputation like as a scientist
researcher no but the peril and 1955 45
46 is the transitive period for the
political forum italian political and i
think that this state in this moment
prefer to to try to reconstruct simply
point the different gaps left by the
world and the problem that i think that
for the warrant the definitely look for
the future of the city is very important
to remark that in nineteen fifty
fifty-five mallanna is the big center of
in development of the north north of
italy and i think that the state at any
first step of the next second war world
didn't recognize the necessity to the
station to recognize the relationship
with the center and for for this reason
i think that is very important the
concept of mono centric in the
definition land and i think that is
important that Widow cannella 40 40
years before the plan after blood this
place recognized at this point of view
and I think that's the problem d &
convention that the plane is not the
state didn't understand the definition
proposal because it is not at that
moment don't evaluate correctly the
needs of the developer of millom I don't
know if in what respects of Lynn upper
body when she is a very polemical and
ambiguous person but I think that her
political profile is not so because
although she didn't she didn't affiliate
the Communist Party she was inspired by
by its ideals and she conducted her own
ideals parallel to them so but what he
avoided was the dependence of the state
in this in this opinion in this case or
of anyone that could meet her or control
her because she had previously lived
under the muscle
his regime she was against the
manipulation and she reacted against any
kind of control so her political project
yes we can say so her political project
is characterized by a dualistic a
dualistic sign can be said like this in
one hand we have the resistance her
attitude of resistance towards the state
towards the establishment on on the
other hand we have her wheel of progress
so this is this bow these two qualities
may inspire us or may invite us to
imagine that she was and big was but i
think that what resolves the question is
that she uses the state to attain her
own purposes even though these purposes
were idealistic and so her relation to
the state is more of resistance and her
ideal of a state is laid by this
attitude of progress it's funny though
because you mentioned that she herself
relies on graham she and yet you could
see how graham she warns actually
against this kind of what you might call
collaboration of things which seem to
work against the state butter but really
entrenching them but but yet like as you
mentioned me she does actually resign at
one point because of this but but you
also mentioned progress and that's
interesting too because of course
there's an ideal of progress but it's
also somewhat ambivalent and that she is
very much trying to supposedly preserve
certain traditions but she sees as being
encroached upon yeah because for her
progress was linked to civilization and
her a concept of civilization was the
life of human beings every day our daily
life that that was what what was a
civilization for her so progress for her
not you know the the institutional image
that the state was promoted in those
years with Brasilia with this greatest
acrobatics that she said the the works
of Nehemiah or other very well known arm
Brazil and architects she she believed
that the civilization and the popular
culture contained the the National
Science for progress because they
represented the the balance between man
and medium and that was related also to
for example the the the Orient idea of
progress in which it is not contrary to
the development of the country or to the
development of technology but it is
based on that balance between men and
medium so that was her idea of progress
ok thank you I think we should open up
to questions thank you very much for
your presentation so I was impressed I
have two questions one for Sylvia and
the other for you your name I don't
remember sorry Francesca yes well I like
to I mean I I wonder why when we analyze
a person politically we use ambiguous I
would like to know which audience you
expect when you say ambi was why she
wasn't big was maybe she was completely
consistent with her with her agenda and
I think you should push her agenda as
the proper agenda for what she did or
what she thought i would like to do to
span on this issue I'm also for
Francesca yes I also miss this this
analysis or your interpretation about
the link the link between the urban
planning the this this plan for me lang
I'm also this in the state I mean I'm
still missing more tougher
interpretation because something should
happen I mean in my case in Spain urban
planning is computed related to power
and you have to analyze this relation
with the community of our cadets and and
also with citizens and Saturn well let's
go question thing all right well um in
what respect to the D active and because
I can just put an example Lina Bo Bardi
based her ideals and her project and in
this idea of a state but he certainly
need the help of the state itself to
reformulate it so that's what makes her
attitude a little bit ambiguous because
she's trying to do her own but in the
other hand she needs the help of the of
the proper object that she's going is
that she's trying to read it really fine
so I have used that term because
precisely I don't want the
misunderstanding of judging it by you
know these disparities it's because of
getting into the christiana of what she
meant by staying what you mean by her
product when can really understand that
it was a coherent project but it can
seem ambiguous because of these double
action that she has with a in respect
away with the state
okay I think this is important to note
that definitely Balon is work with the
deputation with the state and at the
first step I think that definitely think
that g 20 proposal good could pin podium
can I help for with legislation Brad can
you want me yo quiero decirles que lo
que sea importante la terrasse camp
incipio do you speak Spanish do you
speak Spanish can it speak Spanish a ver
ka soo Ryun una cosa que es important
denote arcade affinity al principio
empezo trabajar como una de los
colaborate horas de la reputation
provincial denier on enters area ananta
meant a una conferencia muy fuerte de
objetivos entre lo que eran a principio
loss plans del reconstr ok
okay it's important to note that Nikki
Nikki that definitely and this era had
he began to work on a deep ravine Selena
together with the deputation of the
provincial deputation deputation of
Milan compartiendo is misma so he kills
sharing the same objectives with them ok
pero el momento que empezo a listener
progress on Oh Cass you don't el estudio
de reconstruction but in the moment of
beginning the study of reconstruction of
the city definitely like oh no ser que
una diferencia importante de Lucas on
sue so he knows he recognizes that
there's an important difference between
his own objectives so he was a suit
either a plan and the objectives of his
plan specifically ok al respeto de lo
que no los objetivos the plan de la
pseudonym him with regards to the
objectives the specific objectives of
the of the official plan of Milan the
official plan of Milan the municipality
the municipality I think that is
sufficient to reconstruct only the gaps
left by the world that is sufficient but
for definitely this reconstruction is
this plan it doesn't resolve the issue
of Milan's expansion
ravikiran otra vez la pregunta SI que
hacer cita stay
can I say witness area
ma su padre polite even en el plan
municipal estamos hablando ESO es la que
me espera contado she's confronted
question ok perfect and definitely
collaborate with the reputation ok and
his political role is the potato sir el
tenia una una chava home he had a job
that was represented pony people he was
a he was a political representative in
Antonia polarity this issue need a
studio in Spanish for instance in the in
the realm of Milan he had he had the
power to make decisions and he had the
ability to to realize the plans of the
urban municipal plan yes you speak
better English than you think soon to
the evident amend a wonder any momentum
que la lo que son los objetivos propios
in when we see what his own objectives
were jakub oh pardon me if I got in on
that were carried out by the news polity
of Milan yah encuentran coincidencia en
avance a policy polkas demasiado they no
longer they don't see a connection
between look at locust lefoux gusta they
no longer see a connection between the
real proposal and the end the sort of
forward-thinking proposal of divinity
and doesn't definitely super itself and
end of the yeah my indefinite suppose
even so there is no longer any any
interference here see I'm in tattoos and
there's more interaction between them
two more questions
hello thank you for the presentations I
guess mine is going to be not a direct
question but more comment on them on
this panel and just me to find the name
of the of the people I'd like to start
with the the last remark of Claire when
she said if I understood correctly that
just a aesthetical was let's say
incorporated whereas the political was
not right and for me was fascinating to
see in a way that what emerged in your
paper is more or less a sort of critique
what was help you know what is happening
with definitely in a way right although
you see some sort of like resistance in
the fanatic you know your sequence of
series of maps what we can see is DHing
in a way this sort of like top-down
planning right the city being organizing
a sort of entire environment you know
like huge exes being traced it down
after this the Second World War and then
it emerges a sort of critique in inner
paper which is the idea of participation
in a way right so the the sort of like
everyday life becomes important you know
and and very much inform it by by by the
people themselves right not by by
planning anymore and this is something
that we see in a bowl party as well and
there is of course sort of connection
right because Lena was very much in
connected connected to the sort of 68
movement in Brazil if you want the
counterculture movement in Brazil which
is you know as you said you know like
the new cinema so and so forth so for me
what is interesting is the idea of
participation emerging here you know in
connection to two very critique of this
state right in connection sorry let's
let's make it more democratic in a way
let's let's include people but it seems
to me that at this precise moment as you
said participation was in a way
incorporated
and became the sort of moto of
neoliberal democracies were not critical
incorporated right so it seems to me
that we are in a moment where
participation itself has to be seen in a
critical perspective if that makes sense
you know where's the idea of identity
that you infa sighs so strongly in
representation in relation to Lina
became very much based on earth it
became a very flattened idea right when
you know we see the sort of
community-based urban development right
when architects invite you know a small
sort of fake communities to participate
in urban planning so and so forth and in
a way it lost the power of resistance so
I'm very much interest to to hear from
you how the sort of read of the critique
that the merchants that saying in the
seventies like may 68 how you read this
historical you know how you take this
this history that you are talking about
to let's say to how do you form your
reading of what is happening now in
France or or or what you know in Milan
or whatever know it can be in Brazil I
don't know the military cup of 1964
almost ended with those revolutionary
ideals and in the case of the Vienna
Vanguard it resisted the dictatorship
because he developed the two super
science of the decade as the cinema novo
that you mentioned and the tropicalia
but that ended by the end of the decade
in 1969 there was a state rule that
prohibited or that
cents worth all kind of artistic
manifestations in the country and the
censorship you know placated all this
movement inertia and so well the critic
that you mention i think it's could be
addressed to the the distance from
reality of of some of these initiatives
they were too enthusiastic too motivated
by their the wheel of change and
sometimes these wheel of change was
quite distance from the reality of
everyday life of the people so in the
case of lina her contributions which are
quite a lot are still quite limited in
relation to the scope that she presented
and so as you said participation in
france during the seventies was was like
critic against estates and so it emerged
in france as its period but actually it
didn't last a long time and like a
paradox the election of the first
socialist president in friends from
summit on the 81 actually began to close
the door to participation in
institutional way so actually did it
yeah it's like yeah it's like a paradox
because this period where the notion of
participation was so present lead to
this control is a shin but actually it
then was finished and during the 80s for
example the social housing builders
never really introduced this way of
producing the building in their
practices so it's already made
limited because housing actually remains
very Sun to rise in France of social
housing was always still today is always
directed by basis that would be perhaps
a big world but but actually it's it's
the credits and money from to build
social housing comes from the state so
actually it was it didn't succeed to
reform it from the inside but today in
France way we observe like renewal
re-emergence of this notion but in a
more but actually it what it is today
presented by the institution so it's a
it's a different context yeah it confirm
what way to your commander yeah yeah
yeah but actually yeah the question is
perhaps in France now what what what is
participation and what are these
objectives when how does it function
I've actually been told we have to cut
so to get lunch thank you very much yeah
so we're gonna reconvene at two thirty
or we're going to start at two thirty so
actually reconvene a little earlier if
you can and for the participants there's
going to be lunch and fuel which is a
small